this isn't some remote rainforest Island
I am indoors in a water park this is the
largest uninterrupted indoor space in
the world there are a few bigger spaces
but they're all got support pillars
holding them up this is just one big
roof in terms of volume this is bigger
than NASA's Vehicle Assembly Building
you could fit the entire houses of
parliment in here twice and still have
room for some more water socket along
with the slides and some cabins
you can rent overnight there is a
tethered balloon that will take you up
the rafters or it will take six
passengers and go for a fly around
inside those panels up there they're
transparent to UV light so that trees
grow here which means that you can get
sunburn indoors but in winter this place
stays at tropical temperatures the
amount of heating cooling water
recirculation required is it's
ridiculous there is no way that a
company could ever afford to build
something like this it would cost far
too much they would never be able to
charge enough for admission to ever make
that back and yet here I am which brings
me to my main question what do you do
with a disused airship hangar that's not
just a theoretical question that's what
this is and actually was it's much
disused as never used this whole
structure was built on an old German
airfield at the turn of the millennium
during the dot-com bubble it was
designed to hold an enormous cargo
carrying airship that was never built
because the company went bankrupt a year
later as the economy crashed the
investors lost most of their money it
costs 78 million euro to build this
thing safe to say they never got most of
that back a company from Malaysia bought
the hangar to knock down price a price
that could in theory be made back over
many years if you say spruce the place
up a bit and charged admission maybe out
of the water slides and the result is
bizarrely the world's largest indoor
waterpark and a fluke of our weird 21st
century economy